[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en el que
los periodistas son los invitados y Con
quienes conversamos de una manera más
distensionada sobre algunos de los
hechos más destacados de esta semana
para conversar sobre los temas que hemos
seleccionado para el día de hoy está con
nosotros Luciana binner ella es
periodista de ADN 40 se conecta desde la
Ciudad de México Luciana Bienvenida al
programa y qué tal termina usted su
semana
Que gusto saludarlos y compartir este
espacio con ustedes Bueno una semana
atareada aquí en México la verdad
bastantes temas sobre todo el poder
judicial pero ahí vamos ahí vamos
y desde México nos vamos hasta Berlín en
Alemania Allí se conecta Javier arguedas
periodista y presentador de noticias de
Dolce vele en español Javier bienvenido
un gusto como siempre tenerlo en el
programa Y qué tal termina usted su
semana allí en Alemania
pues parecido ha sido una semana por
supuesto ajetreada Aunque ahora uno
tiene una sensación de que todas las
semanas son ajetreadas aquí tenemos una
pequeña Esperanza porque parece que por
fin llega ya la primavera con
temperaturas cálidas algo que aquí en
Berlín hemos estado esperando desde hace
meses Así que siente que quedarse con lo
bueno merecidas esas buenas temperaturas
allí en la capital alemana y aquí en el
estudio de France 24 nos acompaña Carlos
Eduardo Sánchez periodista venezolano
director y presentador del programa la
mañana del Canal ntn24 Carlos bienvenido
aquí a una semana en el mundo y qué tal
termina usted su semana Santiago Qué
gusto gracias por la invitación Bueno
una semana muy noticiosa de este lado
del mundo reuniones de presidentes que
marcan la agenda informativa que están
ocurriendo en estos últimos días y por
supuesto una agenda política movida
entre Colombia Venezuela todo este
conflicto la crisis venezolana y hemos
estado trabajando mucho pero gracias por
la invitación es un gusto los tres
tenerlos aquí en el programa les
recuerdo también a los televidentes que
ustedes pueden acompañarnos a través de
sus opiniones comentarios y preguntas
estamos en las redes sociales no se
encuentran como arroba
franz24_s o guión al piso arroba
santilogo que es mi cuenta personal y la
etiqueta para que dejen los comentarios
numeral una semana en el mundo f24 todo
pegado todo junto déjenos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas entramos en
materia comenzamos en el continente
africano porque nos tomó por sorpresa en
la mayoría de las redacciones ya lo
compartiremos con los invitados un
repentino estallido de violencia en
Sudán debido a una disputa por el poder
entre un general del ejército y el líder
de un grupo paramilitar los
enfrentamientos en las calles de jartum
han dejado varios fallecidos también
miles de personas han tenido que evacuar
esta ciudad El Éxodo de los habitantes
de la capital pues cada vez es más
marcado con el paso de las horas el
mundo observa con recelo esos intentos
por Establecer un cese el fuego que
no logra prolongarse y temen por el
estallido de una nueva crisis en otro
punto en el continente africano todo por
una lucha por un gran motín y por poder
comienzo entonces dándole la palabra a
Luciana a Luciana Bueno a nosotros acá
en France 24 nos tomó un poco por
sorpresa este estallido de violencia en
Sudán perspectivas opiniones de lo que
ha sido esta semana Sangrienta hay que
decirlo en este país africano
Sin lugar a dudas creo que a todos nos
toma un tacaleada tan rápida de la
violencia ahora bien tía había varias
antecedentes no desde el 2019 cuando se
derroca el gobierno de ir empieza esta
negociación entre dos grupos que
finalmente son dos grupos uno del
ejército tradicional digamos y el otro
Un grupo paramilitar se firma también
este acuerdo para incluir a los
paramilitares en el ejército tradicional
Pero hay una lucha de poder que viene
digamos escalando en el nivel de
violencia y creo que esta es la
consecuencia que estamos viviendo ahora
bien me quedo pensando siento que desde
latinoamérica pocas veces volteamos a
ver a África hasta que ocurren cosas de
esta magnitud y creo que ahí tendríamos
que hacer una autocrítica de lo poco que
seguimos lo que pasa en otros lugares
del mundo no
claro además que siempre estamos
reportando son este tipo de hechos de
violencia o malas noticias y nos
reportamos algunas cosas positivas que
suceden en ese continente le doy la
palabra a Javier en Berlín sus opiniones
sobre este tema Qué sensación les ha
dejado allí en Alemania y en Dolce vele
esta noticia
bueno efectivamente el caso de Sudán es
uno de esos muchos casos en realidad de
países que tienen conflictos graves y
que rezagamos rezagamos definitivamente
en las reacciones hay que decirlo pero
también nos rezagamos porque los ha
rezagado la comunidad internacional y yo
creo que el ángulo interesante aquí son
los esfuerzos de Paz apoyados en este
caso principalmente por Estados Unidos
que ahora está en el foco de las
críticas por una vez más como en muchas
otras ocasiones haber tenido una visión
relativamente ingenua de El Avance de
ese proceso para convertir a ciudadano
en una democracia incluso cuando estaba
estallando la violencia todavía eh
veíamos al gobierno estadounidense
hablando de que esta era una oportunidad
para lograr una transición democrática
Pero la realidad es que nunca hubo una
transición democrática civil real en
Sudán siempre estuvo el país ha estado
controlado por militares militares que
por lo que viendo en este momento
independientemente de suscripciones
internas no quieren someterse a un
régimen civil eso es lo que muchas veces
hemos visto como lectura de este
conflicto esto quiere decir que también
para efectos de como Nosotros hemos dado
la cobertura de la noticia en estos
momentos como suele ser típico nos
enfocamos más en el drama humano en lo
que está implicando esto para los
ciudadanos pero si esto continúa vamos a
ir cada vez más al trasfondo y sobre
todas las implicaciones internacionales
que también hay que abordar y paso a
darle la palabra aquí en el estudio de
France 24 Carlos sus opiniones y
impresiones yo creo que no solo Estados
Unidos Fue ingenuo en creer que iba a
haber democracia en Sudán creo que todos
fuimos ingenuos cuando hay un personal
militar en disputa o manejando esa
transición creo que es muy difícil que
se dé la democracia creo que los casos
no solo en África sino en el resto del
mundo hablan de que por esa vía no es no
debe ser un militar que además
irrumpió de manera violenta en el poder
el esté hablando de democracia con un
gobierno democrático como lo es el
gobierno de los Estados Unidos ahora a
mí me preocupa mucho la alerta que emite
Naciones Unidas falta agua falta
alimentos hay una guerra civil en curso
en Sudán Y pareciera que no es de el
interés del resto del mundo que está
viviendo sus propias crisis pequeñas
medianas pero que debe mirar también a
ese continente hermano a ese continente
que a veces se torna muy violento y que
pasa por muchas penurias Santiago aquí
hay hay varios paralelos que podemos
hacer con la región y con otros otras
esquinas del planeta y es como lo decía
en la introducción del tema Aquí hay una
disputa por un botín y es esa riqueza
mineral en particular el oro que tiene
Sudán Y qué es lo que prácticamente se
están disputando estos dos estos dos
frentes el ejército y este grupo
paramilitar pero también está en una
zona que es bastante complicada a nivel
político de a nivel de seguridad los
países de la región también son un poco
inestables y hay muchas disputas solo
por mencionar alguna esas discrepancias
que hay entre Etiopía Sudán y Egipto por
la presa que va a activar Etiopía en los
próximos meses que reduciría un poco el
caudal del río Nilo y eso afectaría a
varios países río abajo por decirlo de
alguna manera
ustedes creen que esto va a empezar a
escalar qué análisis se puede hacer
desde la perspectiva
periodística que esto va a escalar poco
a poco y nos va a tener no solamente
esta semana sino los próximos días
titulando nuestros medios comentando y
analizando sobre la situación en Sudán
que es un país con un historial de
violencia bastante largo hago la ronda
la inversa le pregunto a Carlos por acá
creo que si un organismo como Naciones
Unidas no toma la batuta pero con
acciones de contundentes y palpables que
se vean como tal no va a haber ese
diálogo Santiago por la paz creo que
esto va a escalar se han dado dos
intentos de alto el fuego y han sido
interrumpidos porque son fuerzas
militares las que están ahí Recuerda que
ambos generales eran quienes habían
quedado al mando del país luego del
golpe de estado y no han podido ponerse
de acuerdo uno reclama que el otro no
quiere entregar el poder que quiere
quedarse allí y la transición se te ha
metido también el componente social este
generar paramilitar dice que él
representa las fuerzas desplazadas o los
sectores desplazados de Sudán es decir
hay una discusión profunda que hay que
dar y deben haber actores de paz que
ayuden Y acompañen a Sudán en este
momento hay un factor del discurso entre
este grupo paramilitar y ese manejo que
le está dando a la ciudadanía Está
tratando que la sociedad se ponga del
lado de ellos pero la sociedad ha estado
Clara en que no quiere militares en el
gobierno quiere una transición
democrática Javier le estamos dando
mucha relevancia a esta parte militar a
este conflicto y estamos dejando de lado
lo que estaba mencionando Carlos han
empezado a escasear los alimentos hay un
Éxodo de la ciudadanía partiendo desde
la capital esto se va a volver un efecto
bola de nieve y vemos una crisis
humanitaria a la vuelta de la esquina
sí efectivamente creo que ese es el
escenario más probable sobre todo
teniendo en cuenta que ya Sudán tenía
problemas humanitarios graves antes de
que esto estallara nosotros por ejemplo
aquí hemos seguido las intervenciones de
una de las personas que más sale
aparecen los medios de comunicación
públicos de Alemania que es la
representante de la organización que
tiene un hijo y ya nos dijo que
prácticamente quiere abandonar el país
está viendo a ver más bien cómo ya el
ejército alemán trató de evacuar eh
algunos de los ciudadanos alemanes del
país tuvo que interrumpir Por cierto esa
esa misión de evacuación pero
lógicamente en el momento en el que las
instancias que pueden servir como puente
para para la ayuda que requieren las
personas abandonan el país lógicamente
la situación para las personas se
deteriora y lo que cuentan en estos
momentos
civiles en Sudán es que hay una
situación de absoluta incertidumbre
porque no saben si por ejemplo si dejan
de escuchar bombardeos y es que es el
fuego o no No saben si esto se va a
prolongar o no No saben si van a tener
electricidad o no Entonces yo creo que
eso eso dificulta muchísimo hacer alguna
proyección optimista del como se va a
desarrollar la explosión Luciana en
México ya le doy la palabra Quiero
preguntarle a Javier en Berlín le
preguntaba por el manejo que se le ha
dado periodísticamente el tema allí en
la cadena para la que él trabaja pero a
nivel de la Unión Europea hay interés
por este tema teniendo Europa otros
frentes humanitarios y de guerra
abiertos digámoslo así está Ucrania está
la crisis migratoria que pues persiste y
Se incrementa ahora con la llegada de
las buenas temperaturas y el verano allí
en el Mediterráneo pero este tema tiene
importancia Bruselas tiene importancia
en la Unión Europea de peso
números claros era para mí la pregunta
sí Javier gracias gracias
Bueno yo diría que por lo menos a nivel
de discurso la Unión Europea hace un
llamado a la paz y dice que por supuesto
necesita o quiere que la que la
situación se se mejore o que cese por lo
menos que se hacen las hostilidades lo
antes posible pero la realidad es que
las intervenciones anteriores Y el rol
que ha tenido en este caso la Unión
Europea en todo el proceso anterior ha
demostrado que no es una prioridad para
la política de Bruselas Habría que ver
si ahora con esta con esta nueva
escalada hay algún esfuerzo mayor pero
lo que ha trascendido hasta ahora es que
siempre se ha apostado porque la
situación estaba en buen curso porque
las partes estaban poniéndose de acuerdo
y porque los esfuerzos por una
democracia estaban funcionando Entonces
cuando la situación tiene esa apariencia
de normalidad pues se reduce el enfoque
que
Luciana para el cierre de este primer
tema su conclusión su cierre impresiones
de lo que vamos a estar viendo en los
próximos días pongámoslo en muy corto
plazo
yo creo que lo que vamos a ver en los
próximos días es en efecto Un aumento de
la violencia se ve muy difícil usted sea
este conflicto ya que no hay digamos
concuerdo en que la única salida tendría
que ver con las presiones
internacionales pero también Creo que el
interés internacional por este tema pues
es limitado no incluso y conectándolo
con lo que decías hace unos minutos la
cobertura periodística creo que en este
momento estamos en el momento de la
novedad donde en todas partes del mundo
estamos llevando la parte humanitaria la
parte de los civiles de los niños
incluso porque Las Guerras finalmente
tienen consecuencias en diferentes
Campos consecuencias múltiples y
brutales para todo el mundo sin embargo
lo que a mí me preocuparía es que si
este conflicto se sigue extendiendo lo
que puede llegar a pasar Es que la
comunidad internacional empiece a
centrarse en sus propios problemas o
incluso en temas que que ocupan más la
atención de los medios internacionales
con países clave no yo yo creo que esto
lo que vamos a ver una transición hacia
la democracia en efecto me parece que es
muy difícil son dos grupos de poder de
hecho hablabas del Oro hace unos minutos
los paramilitares están financiados
justamente por las minas de oro en Sudán
por otro lado el ejército tradicional
que todos los ejemplos que tenemos a
nivel internacional es que es muy
difícil Que suelten el poder es muy
difícil la transición hacia la
democracia entonces creo que se vienen
días semanas meses complicados y quizás
una una guerra civil en curso no Y
además que la comunidad internacional ya
ha dado muestras con algunos ejemplos
que puede simplemente olvidar un
conflicto Pese a que esté activo lo digo
porque esta semana analizamos la
situación en yemen y si no es porque hay
una pequeña luz de Esperanza de un
posible inicio de diálogo para buscar la
paz en yemen no estaríamos hablando de
ese país en los medios internacionales
sobre ese conflicto tan difícil este
puede también llegar a convertirse en un
conflicto olvidado si llega a
desarrollarse como tal Esperemos que la
situación sea completamente diferente
Vámonos ahora para nuestra región
traigamos un poco la la actualidad
informativa nuestro continente un poco
más cerca de nuestra realidad y eso nos
lleva a hablar de El canciller ruso
sergei lab Rob que estuvo esta semana de
visita por América Latina países como
Brasil Venezuela Nicaragua y Cuba
estuvieron en su agenda una gira que
promete o prometía establecer apoyos
reforzar las relaciones bilaterales con
estos países con los que son tal vez los
mejores aliados de Rusia en América
Latina pero que recibe Rusia a cambio
qué tan fructífera fue esa Gira le
preguntó a Carlos aquí en el estudio yo
lo veo como la reafirmación o
ratificación de una relación que es
simbiótica
régimen como el de Rusia o un gobierno
como el de Rusia que está agrediendo a
un país en este momento que es Ucrania
que está planteando una guerra de
agresión así lo ha definido la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas está
diciéndole de alguna manera sus
contradictor que es Estados Unidos otra
Potencia de occidente una potencia
mundial Hey estoy bien con mis aliados
desde otra parte del mundo desde donde
también te puede enfrentar Por qué
Porque estos regímenes Bueno hay un caso
especial Brasil es un caso especial se
reúne también el canciller labrof con el
canciller de Brasil con el gobierno de
Brasil con el presidente que es un
gobierno democrático que ganó Lula da
Silva por la vida democrática Pero hay
casos especiales Nicaragua Cuba y
Venezuela en donde se reúne el canciller
labrov con representantes de regímenes
que de alguna manera tratan de distraer
la atención o desviarla cuando en sus
patios están pasando cosas muy graves
sus fechorías internas y le dice también
a ese contradictor Estados Unidos que se
comporta como el policía del mundo
Oye tengo el apoyo de una potencia
económica militar con poder de veto en
el consejo de seguridad de Naciones
Unidas como Rusia que me vino a visitar
y eso entonces Carlos Si genera miedo en
Washington preocupa en Washington esta
gira de lado yo creo que no yo creo que
no pero genera preocupación Santiago por
la el tono del discurso que se puedan
asumir por ejemplo desde Nicaragua donde
se están violando los los Derechos
Humanos donde está prometiendo Daniel
Ortega enviarle más presos políticos con
ese etiqueta se los pone a Estados
Unidos quiere más preso político yo se
los envío Qué es eso el mundo va a
callar frente a ese tipo de situaciones
es por la subida del tono y la
envalentonada que toman estos tres
regímenes de la región con la visita del
gobierno ruso en representación por
supuesto de su cancillería
y Luciana su opinión Esta visita de laft
América Latina que recibe Rusia aquí a
cambio Pues yo creo que lo que está
buscando Rusia es apoyo diplomático por
un lado y por otro lado
relaciones comerciales después de todo
lo que ocurrió a partir de la invasión
ahora bien a mí lo que me parece
interesante es el caso de Brasil no me
parece que Lula da Silva es una apuesta
bastante arriesgada Porque además
empieza empieza con esa reunión y ya
hubo reacciones por parte de la Unión
Europea por parte de Estados Unidos Me
parece que el tema de Brasil y de Lula
da Silva es un Lula da Silva buscando
una digamos un liderazgo regional no es
la primera vez que lo hace tiene una
carrera muy amplia y ahí es donde yo
pondría el acento no Y ese es el caso
que a mí me parece Interesante como Lula
da Silva recibe alabrov y le manda un
mensaje a Estados Unidos y fuera eso
Estados Unidos también ya le hizo
advertencias a Brasil bájale un poco el
tono Brasilia tranquilo vamos con calma
entendemos esa diplomacia Y esa política
exterior brasileña
multipolar Amigo de todos pero con calma
Ese fue el mensaje de la Casa Blanca
Javier las perspectivas y la opinión
Desde allí desde Europa Cómo se ve Esta
visita desde el otro lado del Atlántico
Bueno lo que queda bastante claro es que
Rusia se afianza cualquier apoyo
internacional que pueda tener y en
América Latina tiene pues estos
gobiernos que o son aliados directamente
o no han condenado la guerra en Ucrania
directamente verdad Entonces por una
parte estamos hablando de posibles votos
en votaciones Por más simbólicas que
sean en Naciones Unidas con países que o
sea han tenido o han votado en contra de
resoluciones que condenaban a Rusia Por
supuesto que Rusia quiere asegurarse de
que los pocos países que han ido por
esta vía continúen por esa vía y
efectivamente como ya lo han mencionado
por supuesto el caso de Brasil es un
caso muy particular Yo creo que esa es
una lectura muy interesante sobre todo
desde aquí de Europa donde se extiende
mucho a romantizar o se tendía podríamos
decir incluso ya a romantizar la figura
de Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva como eh
sobre todo en la prensa digamos que
tiende más hacia la izquierda que dice
Bueno finalmente volvió un gobierno
democrático Un gobierno comprometido con
el medio ambiente se ponía un poco como
una figura de héroe que además había
resistido los intentos por eliminarlo de
del de la Esfera política digamos y
ahora resulta que está de facto por lo
menos a la lectura de de Europa alineado
con Rusia alineado con china en una
retórica abiertamente anti
estadounidense yo creo que lo
interesante aquí es que uno puede
observar que lo que une a estos países
es esa retórica anti estadounidense Más
allá de que tengan realmente tal vez
valores tan comunes con Rusia o modelos
de gobiernos similares a los de Rusia yo
creo que eso también es algo importante
Carlos Luciana pero ustedes lo ven así
tan anti estadounidense porque Lula
también ya estuvo en Estados Unidos
claro y rectificó al final del camino
tuvo obligado por declaraciones del
departamento de estado por altos Voceros
del gobierno de Estados Unidos y por la
opinión pública que decir que condenaba
de Rusia contra Ucrania no lo había
dicho de hecho había dicho no voy a
enviar municiones que se producen en
Brasil para que Ucrania se defienda Ando
buscando un grupo de amigos de países
aliados que podamos ofrecerle una
alternativa de paz pero tuvo que
rectificar de alguna manera o poner el
resaltador en esa etiqueta de que Rusia
sí está agrediendo a Ucrania
Luciana usted que fue la que trajo el
tema de Brasil a la mesa no sé si a
usted le ha llamado la atención la
fuerza con la que Brasil está en la
escena internacional en este momento
Lula Silva está determinado hacer de
Brasil un nuevo actor internacional lo
vimos en China el canciller Alemán de
visita en Brasil gira por los países del
mercosur Estados Unidos ahora Rusia
esto promete por lo menos catapultar
otra vez a Brasil para hacer un país de
importancia internacional cómo lo ve
Sí yo creo que Lula da Silva Sin lugar a
dudas está buscando ese liderazgo en la
región sobre todo en Latinoamérica de
los países que son o se autodenominan
digamos ya lo podemos discutir a
profundidad pero de izquierda No es
cierto que tuvo que matizar su discurso
incluso salió su asesor político a
morima a dar algunas entrevistas ahí
matizando un poco lo que se había dicho
yo no creo que es una a ver yo creo que
en el yo soy vivo en México trabajo en
México pero soy Argentina y creo que la
narrativa anti estadounidense es algo
que en Sudamérica digamos llama mucho la
atención que es bastante popular y que
permea un poco en el ánimo social y creo
que esto lo utiliza muy bien Lula da
Silva ahora no se va a enfrentar
directamente a Estados Unidos porque
también es una persona muy inteligente
no pero digamos sí creo que de alguna
manera esa narrativa puede permear en el
ánimo social puede permanecer en la
sociedad y en la gente que lo sigue no
hace muchos años por cierto Sí ya
veremos estas relaciones que se han
empezado a trazar aquí en América Latina
Cómo terminan una vez termine la guerra
en ucra porque aquí había coqueteos de
todos lados miren Esa esa propuesta que
hizo Brasil diciendo que bueno que el
plan de paz para Ucrania pasaba por kiev
cediendo por completo la Península de
crimea a Rusia y esto obviamente en kiev
y al presidente es el esquí no le gustó
mucho Les propongo que cerremos el tema
de la profe y su gira por América Latina
en este punto porque tenemos que pasar a
otro tema que también tiene mucho de
donde cortar Y es porque a lo largo de
esta semana hubo mucha expectativa por
esa visita del presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro a Estados Unidos en donde
se reunió con el presidente Joe biden el
encuentro estuvo marcado por diferentes
temas como la búsqueda de fondos para
imponer en marcha o fortalecer esa
implementación del acuerdo de paz con
las Farc un acuerdo que fue firmado en
el año 2016 también reforzar por
supuesto esas relaciones comerciales y
políticas entre los dos países promover
la paz Total que es el proyecto de
bandera del presidente Petro y también
pues hubo espacio para hablar de
Venezuela ya le voy a Le voy a dar la
palabra a Carlos que sé que quiere
hablar de este tema la lucha contra el
narcotráfico que también es otro tema
abanderado del presidente colombiano te
doy la palabra Carlos Santiago todos los
temas aparte del de Venezuela son los
temas normales que un presidente debe
tocar en una visita de este nivel con el
presidente de la primera potencia del
mundo si es que se considera Estados
Unidos así Colombia de alguna manera
este Petro no está a la izquierda o la
derecha en el poder tiene una buena
relación con los Estados Unidos
el tema del apoyo creo que se va a
mantener pero lo complicado está en lo
que fue hacer agenda oculta o media el
gobierno o el presidente Gustavo Petro
el gobierno de Colombia que es hablar
con el presidente Joe biden para retirar
sanciones que hay que decirlo no son
sanciones contra Venezuela como país
sino sanciones contra empresas creadas
por colaboradores del régimen un régimen
que está siendo investigado por la Corte
Penal Internacional por crímenes de lesa
humanidad donde muere gente en mazmorras
en cárceles subterráneas donde no hay
respeto por los Derechos Humanos donde
se persigue hay más de 280 presos
políticos en Venezuela el mundo creo que
se está acostumbrando a vivir con una
guerra en Ucrania de agresión y de
Invasión por parte de Rusia con una
cantidad de presos políticos en
Nicaragua un país de Centroamérica que
probablemente no le preocupa a muchos
países del Mundo a muchos gobiernos o a
la gente como tal y una cantidad de
presos políticos en Venezuela ahora será
capaz el presidente Gustavo Petro de
ahondar en esa propuesta de salida a la
crisis en Venezuela que no tiene solo un
actor que es Nicolás maduro y el segundo
actor es Estados Unidos como sancionador
tiene una cantidad de millones siete
millones de venezolanos que están por
fuera hoy porque huyeron de una crisis
esa es una realidad será capaz el
presidente Petro de mirar toda la crisis
al 100% o sólo la parte de un gobierno o
de un régimen que les afín
ideológicamente ahí está la clave
Santiago eso llama mucho la atención
Luciana ese papel que ha asumido Gustavo
Petro de abanderado esta crisis
venezolana de la imagen Venezolana en en
el exterior si el ex presidente
colombiano Iván Duque era la abanderado
en promover todas estas Este cierres
diplomáticos y económicos a Venezuela
Petro tomó la bandera completamente en
el sentido contrario
sí qué bueno que lo mencionan Me parece
que eso es clave no de marcarse de todo
lo que hizo Iván Duque que por cierto
pues no le fue muy bien y creo que por
otro lado también y relacionado un poco
a lo que estábamos a lo que estábamos
hablando así como Lula da Silva parece
querer desmarcarse de todo lo que hace
el resto de latinoamérica Petro yo
siento que es lo que intenta hacer es
ganarse esa medalla Siri logra algún
Avance en el conflicto con Venezuela se
va a llevar digamos parte de ese
reconocimiento y parte de ese liderazgo
incluso quería llevarse las mesas de
negociaciones que estaban planteadas
para México justamente hacia hacia
Colombia ustedes digamos lo tendrán
mucho más claro
el tema Carlos Santiago Pero y yo ahí sí
creo que digamos hay una parte de
polémica Pero yo sí estoy de acuerdo en
que muchas veces las sanciones la
historia nos ha demostrado que no
funcionan entonces con esta con este
discurso digamos Pedro o sea llevado la
bandera del conflicto de Venezuela No
creo que tenga Muchos avances pero creo
que si los tiene puede ser un botín
político muy pero muy interesante muy
interesante Javier su opinión sobre este
tema
Bueno yo creo que es natural que
Colombia en este caso Gustavo Petro sea
quien maneje estos temas en el escenario
internacional porque es el país vecino
porque no le conviene Obviamente que
haya ni fricciones ni ni problemas con
su país vecino y sin embargo yo creo que
lo que siempre llama la atención en el
caso Gustavo Petro por lo menos desde la
perspectiva que uno tiene aquí es que
pone metas sumamente altas sumamente
ambiciosas
va a haber una paz total va a haber cero
sanciones para Venezuela pero sí
democracia eh vamos a cambiar la forma
de combatir el narcotráfico verdad O sea
todos estos temas importantes que hay en
las agendas digamos los los presenta con
una visión probablemente deseable pero
sumamente ambiciosa y difícil de
alcanzar y ahí lo que creo que habría
que ver es cuál va a ser la reacción
específica de Washington en cuanto a
acciones siendo que en realidad no me da
la impresión de que América Latina en
términos generales sea la prioridad uno
del gobierno de Joe biden
y siendo que hay otros temas en los que
se pueden conseguir avances muy muy
palpables que tal vez son más del
interés de la Administración Como por
ejemplo el tema de la lucha contra el
cambio climático así que no me
sorprendería si de lo que resulta todo
esto es más acción en esos aspectos y en
esos ámbitos que por ejemplo en el tema
del narcotráfico o en el tema de las
sanciones contra bueno contra Venezuela
pero
coincido Javier en en esa pregunta en
tenerla sobre la mesa y es que tanta
sintonía hay en los intereses de
Washington y en los intereses de Bogotá
y otra cosa que rescato Javier Luciano y
Carlos es que a pesar de este cambio
político que ha tenido Colombia con la
administración Petro Colombia y este
presidente siguen viendo a Estados
Unidos como un Aliado importante no fue
un país que entró a atacar la
administración y a la casa blanca sino
que pese a las diferencias políticas y a
tener algunos temas en común es
necesario seguir conversando con
Washington así se esté de acuerdo no en
algunos en algunos puntos Pese a que
como dice Javier América Latina no es la
prioridad para el gobierno de biden para
el cierre de este tema entonces Carlos
Pues en esta línea no es una prioridad
entonces tanto lobby del gobierno
colombiano tantas críticas que le hizo
Petro el gobierno de Estados Unidos pero
a la casa blanca también quiso ir a
tomarse la foto con el presidente biden
bueno porque lo decía Luciana quiere de
alguna manera tener una medalla de
liderazgo en lo político y hay que
dársela si se logra por ejemplo que en
Venezuela las elecciones del 2024
anunciada ya por el cne cuestionado por
los sectores políticos de oposición en
Venezuela se van a dar elecciones
presidenciales si esa elecciones tienen
una observación internacional
independiente porque es que las
elecciones en Venezuela lo que el
régimen vende como elecciones como
comicios tienen observación amañada
observación del bolsillo o del bolso de
quien está en el poder que Nicolás
Maduro el partido socialista Unido de
Venezuela Si eso lo logra Gustavo Petro
Y si maduro reconoce que hay una buena
porción de los venezolanos es quien no
está de acuerdo con su plan político y
que pudiera salir del Poder y los
militares lo aceptan Gustavo Petro va a
ser el gran ganador eso que no hizo
Chávez en la región lo va a ganar
Gustavo Petro porque es un presidente
legítimo lo veremos en el desarrollo
Bueno después de Esta visita washington
Las repercusiones que esto tendrá en las
próximas semanas pasamos al bloque final
del programa y pasamos a consultarle a
nuestros invitados por un comentario
sobre algún tema específico de la
actualidad en este segmento pues es una
ronda rápida sobre alguno de los temas
que les voy a plantear y Les propongo un
tema de agenda de France 24 dado que hoy
hemos estado presentando Y destacando a
lo largo de la programación a través de
reportajes e informes la situación de
las mujeres en Afganistán completamente
relegadas socialmente apartadas de la
formación académica y de la vida social
comienzo preguntándole a la invitada de
este programa de hoy a Luciana en México
situación de las mujeres en Afganistán
un comentario
absolutamente brutal creo que lo que
hemos visto desde que los talibanes
tomaron el poder es como los derechos de
las mujeres se han ido socavando cada
vez más y esto tiene repercusiones en
otros ámbitos no el pnud de de Naciones
Unidas sacó un informe hace poco de como
ha disminuido la producción económica en
Afganistán casi un 20% desde que los
talibanes asumieron el poder es decir
que las mujeres tenemos un un lugar muy
importante la producción económica de
los países obviamente no es la única no
es la única causa pero sí una de ellas y
por otro lado rapidísimo Pero no puedo
dejar de pensar y lo que nos estamos
viendo también en Estados Unidos de cómo
los derechos conquistados de nosotras
las mujeres muchas veces pueden ser
echados para atrás en un segundo está
bien su comentario
Bueno yo quisiera sacar dos ideas
brevemente la primera es que hay que
considerar que la situación de las a
pesar de que el lente sobre todo de
occidente siempre tiende a contar esta
historia de que estaban reprimidas luego
vino digamos el cambio en el régimen y
tuvieron un montón de conquistas y luego
ahora se las están quitando es válido
definitivamente para la capital pero no
necesariamente para las zonas Rurales
donde muchas veces continuaron bajo El
dominio talibán eh En ese sentido no es
en todo el país que han existido estas
conquistas y no es en todo el país donde
hubo cambios drásticos y esto lo dice
sobre todo también la encargada
principal del servicio afgano de de no
es idea mía y el otro aspecto a
considerar es que a la hora de ver cómo
se puede solucionar esta situación Cómo
se puede ayudar a las mujeres en
Afganistán hay que considerar también Y
estos polémicos pero es cierto también
que hay mujeres que han abrazado ese
concepto de vida que ahora viven en paz
y ya no en guerra y que de hecho están
satisfechas con la situación que existe
actualmente en esos aspectos debería
enfocarse una ayuda y entender esa
diferencia también importante ese esa
aclaración esa perspectiva de Javier
desde la ciudad de Berlín Carlos para el
cierre este comentario Yo sí Lamento que
haya un retroceso en las conquistas de
las mujeres en Afganistán como lo decía
Luciana lo lamento mucho que no hayan
oportunidad de estudios secundario y de
universidad para una mujer impacta en el
desarrollo de un país y eso se está
viendo ya en Afganistán con la llegada
del talibán al poder Ese es el resultado
hay que darle a la mujer su lugar en la
sociedad y respetarlas además y
entendiendo el contexto cultural en el
que está esa sociedad respetando el tema
religioso que es lo que prevalece
también allí debe haber cabida para esa
libertad mínima bien merecida de la
mujer en Afganistán otro comentario para
el cierre porque comenzó la filbo que es
la Feria Internacional del Libro de
Bogotá Allí está presente France 24 y yo
quiero conocer los gustos literarios de
nuestros invitados que están leyendo en
este momento que nos nos recomiendan yo
rápidamente les muestro que estoy
leyendo yo en este momento personalidad
de poder Aquí lo tengo en mis manos
recién lo comencé a leer y es un perfil
sobre cómo la se construyó Europa a
nivel político en el siglo XX y habla de
personajes como Lenin stalin Mussolini
margaret thatcher Cómo construyeron su
su poder a partir de su personalidad y
rápidamente una novela de historia rusa
las brujas de San Petersburgo habla de
dos princesas montenegrinas muy cercanas
al zar Nicolás que fueron conocidas en
la historia por haber sido las que
llevaron a Gregorio Rasputín al palacio
de invierno en San Petersburgo sabemos
lo que desencadenó este personaje en la
historia de Rusia rápidamente Luciana
que está leyendo o que no recomienda
estos últimos años he estado leyendo
muchas mujeres la verdad el mal de la
taiga lo acabo de terminar de Cristina
Rivera Garza es maravilloso Es una
novela de una una investigadora que la
mandan a la selva También estuve leyendo
unas crónicas mejor que la ficción
estaba compilado por Jorge Carrión son
pequeñas Crónicas de cronistas de todo
el mundo interesantísimo también muy
recomendado buena recomendación Carlos
yo me fui a la biblioteca muy viejita de
mi papá que en paz descanse está en el
cielo y me estoy leyendo Porque mi hijo
me ha pedido retomar lectura sobre la
literatura de Gabo de García Márquez
pero yo me fui a un autor venezolano En
eso estoy en este momento una novela se
llama las lanzas coloradas es de Arturo
usler prieti y narra en realismo mágico
que es muy interesante un episodio
cuando José Tomás bobes que era un
general realista asoló el llano
venezolano y me ha me ha conectado con
Mis raíces diez años después de estar
viviendo fuera de Venezuela buena esa
conexión y Javier para el cierre sus
recomendados
Yo tengo un libro de yulitchee una
autora alemana es el libro más reciente
que le digo que se llama año nuevo que
también me fijé también está en español
es una autora Entonces está haciendo
bastante
alabada aquí en Alemania porque Presenta
una perspectiva muy real digamos de los
sentimientos y del universo de
sentimientos de las personas trata
digamos un trauma de infancia en un
viaje a lanzarote bastante interesante
recomendado y el otro libro no es nuevo
es del año 2015 me lo estoy leyendo
ahora se llama narcoamérica y va tras el
resto de la cocaína en todo el
continente americano sumamente
interesante para entender los contextos
Y me sorprendió que empezaba justamente
en Costa Rica en mi país Bueno pues ahí
tienen ustedes variada literaria hoy no
terminamos con temas de agenda y
editoriales para la próxima semana sino
con esto recomendados de lectura Gracias
a ustedes por haber estado con nosotros
Carlos Javier Luciana Muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
programa ustedes pueden seguir dejando
los comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con France 24
[Música]